sparks fly at the biggest ever wild
woods day thousands of people enjoyed
the 9th wild woods day and special
sparks will fly event look out for more
on the website at www k /r DM there are
two photographs showing visitors
enjoying trying out the sport of slack
lining which looked awful and one of
mythical champion boreas sefa arriving
to collect a glass bead as part of the
sparks will fly event set to take place
in Chalcedon july the sixth more news at
WWF parks will fly gog UK Maureen's gift
is open for applications and offers five
thousand pounds for local projects if
you're involved with a local community
group and could do with a cash boost
Maureen's gift may be able to help in
memory of Maureen Vince a Rockford
community champion Maureen's gift offers
financial support for charities local
residents groups and voluntary
organizations to make a positive
difference in their community projects
we support include helping older people
and those with disabilities equipment
for art groups and play groups
supporting people back into work for an
application pack contact Rockford
housing Oh 300 1 2 3 35 14 or a 800 oh
12 1991 the email addresses contact us
at sanctuary dash housing co uk and
quote Maureen's gift the closing date
for the next application is the 31st of
December 2012 rochford Housing
Association limited and exempt charity
is a subsidiary of sanctuary housing
association and exempt charity
infocus your local councillor there are
39 councillors representing 19 Ward's or
areas of the district following the
local elections in May the political
composition of the council is as follows
31 conservative councillors for liberal
Democrat to green to Rochford district
residents councillors you will find
details of the counselor who represents
you on rochford district council and for
more information contact member services
on 0 1 702 318 140 for details of
meetings or check the council's website
at www k meetings of the executive and
the main statutory and regulatory
committees are usually held at the Civic
sweet Raley and are open to members of
the public there may occasionally be
some items of confidential business when
the public will be asked to leave the
meeting there is also a review committee
which is there to help review and
develop areas of work members of the
public who have written in about a
planning application may register to
speak of the development committee when
the application is being considered
guidance on public speaking at the
development committee may be obtained
from member services or from the
council's website and these are
counselors ashington includin mrs. TJ
cape on conservative TG cut more
conservative and council leader barling
and sutton MJ steptoe conservative down
hall and roar off' CI black liberal
democrat ra autumn also Liberal Democrat
found less and great wakelin t equal
twin conservative cg cedars conservative
and also this is bj wilkins conservative
Grange to MIT mystery mrs. Lumley both
liberal democrats hawk or North both
conservative rd pointer and mrs. je
McPherson hawk well South conservative
again p a cape on mrs. H la Glynn Hawk
well West jrf Mason and mrs. C n mason
Rochford district residents hotly
central all conservative KH hudson mrs.
CA weston and BTW Hazelwood hockley
north mr carter conservative hockley
west em Maddox conservative hullbridge
em hoi green party mrs. AV Hale
conservative mrs. D hoy Green Party
Lodge both conservative dmarek and IH
Ward and really central both
conservative mrs. P aves and mrs. C row
and the following five areas are all
conservatives Rockford mrs. GA Lucas Gil
k j gordon and JP kotas Swain park mrs.
JM oxford and te mountain trinity DJ
spurring and je grey wheatley JD Griffin
and mrs. MJ Webster White House PFA
Webster and SP Smith out and about who
what when where how clubs and societies
supporting carers and families together
known as scarf scarf provides support to
young carers aged 8 to 18 years offering
group sessions one to one support in
schools trips outings and training adult
carers support is for adults caring for
an adult partner adult child friend or
neighbor offering monthly cafes
one-to-one support and trips
all carers are provided with information
and advice relating to relevant services
benefits training and information days
and for this contact email is info @
scarfed oqk telephone 012 687 418 double
one or visit w WC avto Guk roach art
group annual exhibition Saturday the
27th of October ten a.m. to four p.m.
and entry is free this is at San
theresa's church hall ashington road
roxford located to the rear of the
church there are regular meetings held
on wednesday evenings between 7 30 and
nine thirty good lighting and facilities
all abilities cater for at this friendly
club who use a variety of media
membership inquiries from beginners and
experienced always welcome reasonable
fees apply and details are on request
contact christine on 0 1 702 586 336 or
john on 079 double 3263 930 the haven
art group they meet weekly every tuesday
between 130 and 3 30 p.m. at some marks
hall some marks field rochford SS for
one PT this is a self-taught social art
group with a number of places available
all abilities welcome it costs two
pounds and to contact number is 0 1 70 2
3 4 650 1 or 0 1 702 4673 28 the next
Railly horticultural society show is the
autumn one on Sunday the second to sep
tember two o'clock til 430 p.m. this is
held at the mill arts & Events Center in
bellingham Lane rayleigh enjoyed
displays of flowers handicrafts and
floral art it costs a pound for entry
children free saddle up for this year's
foul ness island bike ride which takes
place on the knife of sep tember 2012
the 23 mile ride is organized by the
rotary club of thought Bay the MLD
kinetic and foul nest parish council and
in 2012 we'll be raising money for South
End mind register early to avoid
disappointment you can do this at WWLP a
rotary events or one word coach UK or
help by volunteering to marshal the
course by contacting rotary dot t bay at
sky calm farmers markets at really high
street market every wednesday from eight
a.m. to 2p n you can buy fresh meat fish
fruit vegetables speciality breads cakes
cheese pies groceries household products
jewelry handbags sweets garden ornaments
pet food and lots more besides taxi
pickup is in the lay-by at the crown pub
and drop off in the lay-by at the clock
rochford farmers market at the WI hall
west street Rochford these are on the
first saturday of every month except
january between nine thirty AM and
1230pm admission is free and you can
contact Oh 17025 4072 to council
committee dates all meetings are held at
Civic sweet to hockey road rayleigh SS
68 eb and they are all at seven thirty
p.m.
review committee on the tenth of July
executive 11th of July council at 17th
of July Development Committee 26th of
July and thirtieth of August review
committee eleventh of sep tember
executive 19th of sep tember audit
committee 26th of sep tember and
development committee 27th or September
if you need further information contact
member services on 0170 2318 140 2012
recycling dates with this edition is a
cut out and keep calendar please cut it
out and keep the calendar which gives
you the dates for your recycling
collections for the rest of the year
don't forget there's plenty of help
available if you are unsure of which
materials go in which bin including our
popular recycling a to Zed facility on
the website which tells you at a glance
what goes where you can find that at wh
the govt UK /recycling a to Zed
alternatively you can telephone customer
services on 0170 2318 one double one or
email customers services at Rochford UK
extra sex left next to or on top of bins
are not collected bin collections remain
as normal on the summer bank holiday
monday always the 27 2012 when it will
be a non recycling week your compostable
bin is collected every week during the
year in the event of severe weather this
winter we will update the website at www
k with the latest information every day
please check it for details
we've had a massive response to our
recycling competition the hard work
you've put in has meant that Rochford
District Council is now officially the
top recycling authority in the country
to celebrate this and to say a big thank
you the council launched a special
competition for school children across
the district we asked youngsters to come
up with a design and slogan about what
the council being named the top
recycling authority in the country meant
to them we were very impressed with the
hundreds of ideas and entries we
received as the youngsters came up with
a huge number of inspiring thoughts
about recycling and the environment
unfortunately we could only choose three
winners one from each of the following
age categories five to eight years nine
to 11 years and 12 to 16 years each of
the lucky winners will see their
pictures and wording displayed on the
side of the collection vehicles which
travel around the district collecting
the materials in addition the winners
received a 25 pounds amazon voucher each
and a composter for their school the
school also received a special wall
clock and thermometer which is made from
recycled plastic cups ethan adams age 12
from swain park school was the winner in
the age 12 to 16 category and got his
inspiration for the picture by looking
at the recycling pages on the council's
website his mom told us that when he was
younger Ethan loved looking out for the
collection vehicles and so he's really
pleased that his design will be featured
on the side of them Ethan usually paints
pictures by holding a paintbrush in his
mouth because he's paralyzed when the
shoulders down as a result of a virus he
contracted as a baby but for this
picture he explained what he wanted to
design and a friend helped him with the
drawing
Lucy Mae aged 9 from Holt farm junior
school Lucy was the winner in the age
nine to eleven category and looked at
some of the images that were already on
the collection vehicles for ideas her
picture represents many different people
carrying out recycling which helps to
influence and encourage the community to
be keen recyclers loosely helps out with
the recycling at home and thinks it's
very important she's very excited about
winning the competition for her age
group and said her family will be really
pleased Adam Vickers aged 7 from hope
farm junior school and second Hawk will
be vers group said he was very very
happy to have come first in the age 5 to
8 category Adam read about the council
being the top recycling Authority in the
country in a local newspaper and the
picture shows him recycling as this is
his job at home for which he gets paid
Tempe Adam thinks it's really important
to recycle otherwise there would be
piles of rubbish and is always better to
use things again rather than making
things from new materials keeping the
district tidy dropping litter is illegal
however according to an environmental
study more than 2 million pieces of
litter are dropped in the UK every
single day litter takes years to break
down causing harm to wildlife and
habitats and there's even evidence to
show that litter contributes to further
crime and a feeling of being unsafe
Lissa isn't only rappers and packaging
but also things like leftover takeaway
food which can attract vermin such as
rats cigarette butts are also classed as
litter and the survey carried out by
keep britain tidy found cigarette litter
on seventy-eight percent of the streets
surveyed cigarette butts are unsightly
and are difficult to clean up smokers
should use an ashtray or dedicated
smoking litter bin or take their litter
home with them councils and other
authorities have responsibility for
keeping public land as litter free as
possible and they have a range of powers
available to them to help tackle litter
problems fixed penalty charges of 50 to
80 pounds can be issued to individuals
who drop litter
and if the offender is prosecuted and
convicted in court the fine could rise
to 2,500 pounds the council can also
serve notices on other duty bodies
businesses land owners and occupiers
compelling them to clear up litter if
you see accumulations of litter in a
public place please report it to the
council note the location type and
amount of litter please call customer
services on 0170 2318 one double one or
email customer services at Rochford
gavotte UK encouraging more sport with
playing pitch strategy the council has
recently put plans in place to ensure
that there are enough playing pitches
for people who want to use them in the
future the playing pitch strategy
supplementary planning document was
adopted on the 17th of April 2012
supplementary planning documents are
used to provide more guidance and detail
on local planning matters in this
instance the playing pitch strategy does
this for the issue of playing pitch
provision across the district and
includes an assessment of the supply and
demand the plane pitch strategy proposes
a number of recommendations and
potential solutions for the issues it
identifies for example one of the issues
identified in the study is the
oversupply of adult football pitches
coupled with an undersupply of junior
and mini football pitches in the
district as such the council will look
to redress this balance in the future
other recommendations include securing
developer contributions from planning
applications to ensure playing pitch
provision and encouraging schools to
sign up to formal community use
arrangements for dual use of school
facilities allowing the wider community
to make use of such facilities a copy of
the playing pitch strategy supplementary
planning document can be viewed online
just search playing pitch strategy at
WWF a govt UK paper copies can be made
available on
quest for further details please contact
the planning policy team on 0 1 702 318
191 or planning dot policy at Rochford
gulf qk benefit overpayment help if
you've received letters from the council
about an overpayment of Housing Benefit
or council tax benefit and you're
finding it difficult to pay this amount
back you can contact our revenues &
Benefits Office for help and advice you
can phone us on 0 1 702 318 0 1 1 e-mail
revenues and benefits at Rochford garvey
UK or you can visit the council offices
at South Street Rochford our officers
will be able to answer questions you
have about overpayments and they'll be
able to discuss a suitable arrangement
for you to repay the amount in
affordable instalments independent
advice on overpayments is also available
from the Citizens Advice Bureau many
people who have overpayments of housing
benefit or council tax benefit sometimes
experience difficulty paying other
outstanding debts and household expenses
if this is happening to you then you can
contact or visit your local CA B for
free and independent advice you can
contact them by phoning 0844 for double
7 08 08 visiting their website at www k
or visit their local offices at back
lane rochford or Civic sweet hockley
road Raley the CA B may be able to
negotiate with creditors on your behalf
you can reduce overpayments of Housing
Benefit or council tax benefit by
telling us about changes in your
circumstances as soon as they happen you
can do this by phoning 0170 2318 197 or
318 198 or email revenues and been
it's at Rochford gávea dr. UK or you can
visit the council offices at South
Street Rochford winners of the prize
draw in our last edition of Rochford
district matters we asked customers to
sign up to our council tax paperless
billing scheme to help cut costs and
protect the environment we would like to
thank the hundreds of customers who
responded to the campaign and signed up
to receive their future bills by email
all were entered into a prize draw to
win one of three 100-pound prizes
congratulations to the winners who were
mr Young from Rochford mr. Weldon from
rayleigh and mr. Dawson from rayleigh
the revenues and benefits team are
responsible for producing printing and
posting thousands of bills and booklets
every year by signing up to get your
future bills by email you will help us
to reduce costs and our carbon footprint
paperless billing is convenient for you
convenient for us and very good for the
environment if you would like to receive
your future bills by email let us know
by emailing your name and address to
paperless billing at Rochford garvey you
k and we will do the rest for you the
revenues and benefits team has announced
their performance figures for 2011-12
despite an increasing workload the
department's performance has exceeded
their targets for the first time the
figures show how well the team have been
doing the latest figures come just a few
months after the team gained the
customer service excellence award for
the second year running the award
recognizes their efforts to continually
improve and develop their service in
response to the needs of its customers
the benefits performance figures are
target's for processing benefit claims
21 days performance was nineteen point
four days target for possess processing
change of circumstances was 12 days and
the performance was eight point six days
you can find the revenues and benefits
team on 0 1 702 31 8 197 or 0 1 702 318
198 or email revenues and benefits at
Rochford gulf qk or visit the council
offices at South Street Rochford
neighbourhood policing and the delivery
of local policing services is a core
part of blueprint the new policing model
introduced by essex police earlier this
year dedicated neighborhood constables
will continue to take the lead for
community engagement within their area
and will work with partner agencies to
find solutions to community issues
supported by neighborhood police
community support officers they will
attend neighborhood meetings and will be
the identified points of contact for
their community will now give you names
and mobile phone numbers of the officers
in your area ashington canoe 'don and
Wakering is PC Steve Thomas his mobile
number is 0 7 80 1 4616 534 hullbridge
is pc emma chambers mobile 078 1395 3703
Rochford is pc paul ledger mobile number
0 7 8 0 1 4616 53 hockley is pc charles
key mobile 077 100 4 6-1 6-1 and in
rayleigh it's PC Steve joins mobile Oh
seven eight one two three nine five
three seven zero three and you can find
out more about neighbourhood policing
and the work Essex Police do at ww Essex
Police UK winners of hate crime logo
competition pupils from Fitz why mark
school rayleigh led the way in a logo
design competition to draw attention to
the help available for victims of hate
crime charity Wilkins katie orchard and
holly Perkins
took the top three places in the
competition organized by Rochford
district hate crime panel and supported
by the Rochford District Community
Safety Partnership the panel has been
set up to promote awareness of hate
crime and works with many different
organizations and community groups to
change people's attitude to others the
logo competition was designed to
encourage young people to think about
hate crime and how victims might be
encouraged to come forward and report
incidents charities winning entry won
her a 50 pounds amazon voucher Katie and
Holly collected a 25 pound voucher and a
10 pound voucher respectively and were
presented with their prizes by the chair
of the hate crime panel Paul Becker's
and the chair of the Oxford District
Community Safety Partnership counselor
Joe McPherson during a school assembly
unfortunately charity was unable to be
at the presentation but received her
reward later Park events success scores
of dog owners and cyclists took
advantage of a free microchipping
service as part of a series of events
held in parks and open spaces across the
district the four events in Great
Wakering Cherry Orchard country park
rochford and rayleigh saw more than 40
dogs fitted with microchips to help
identify them should they ever go astray
the free bike taking service proved just
as popular with 50 bicycles being fitted
over the four events all those who
completed an on-site survey were entered
into a prize draw with a 15 pounds Marks
and Spencers voucher as prizes the
winning visitors were from Great
Wakering miss MERS H Mitchell of great
wakering Cherry Orchard was mrs. our
tents le of Rayleigh Rochford MERS tea
green of Rochford and freely mrs. K
baglietto
rochford district matters is edited by
patrick john and produced by rockford
district council who can be found at
three to nineteen south street rochford
SS for one BW their telephone number is
0 1 702 546 366 and their website is at
WWE r govt UK the paper is printed by
Charmin & Company Limited and that
brings us to the end of a situation
which was recorded by volunteers from
the rayleigh Rockford and castle point
talking newspapers for the blind at
their studio in rockford